welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 21 and
we're gonna learn the success
lessons and advice from billionaires
[Music]
enjoy
[Music]
young people globally want to be like
elon musk
what's your advice to them i think
that probably they shouldn't want to be
you i think it sounds better than it is
okay
um yeah it's
uh not as much fun being me as you'd
think
i don't know you don't think so there's
definitely it could be worse for sure
but it's um
i i i'm not sure i would i'm not sure i
want to be me
okay but
if
you know i i think advice i mean if you
want to make
progress in things i think that
um the best analytical framework
for understanding the future is physics
i'd recommend studying the uh
the thinking process around physics like
not just not not the equations i mean
equations certainly they're helpful
but the the the way of thinking in
physics is
the it's the best framework for
understanding things that are
counterintuitive
[Music]
and you know always taking the position
that you are some degree wrong and your
goal is to be less wrong over time
the i think one of the biggest mistakes
people generally make and i'm guilty of
it too is wishful thinking
you know like you want something to be
true even if it isn't true
um and so you ignore the things that
you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true
this is a very difficult trap to avoid
and like i said certainly one that i
find myself
in having problems with
but if you just take that approach of
you're always to some degree wrong
and your goal is to be less wrong and
and solicit critical feedback
particularly from friends like friends
particularly friends
if somebody loves you they want the best
for you they don't want to tell you the
bad things
um so you have to ask them
okay you know and said really i really
do want to know
and then they'll tell you and the way i
tend to view problems is from a from a
physics
standpoint and i think i think physics
is a good analytical framework
um and one of the key things in in
physics is to reason from first
principles
um this is contrary to the way most
human reasoning takes place which is by
analogy
um reason for first principles just
means that you you figure out
what are the fundamental what are the
fundamental truths or
or things that are pretty people are
pretty sure of fundamental truths
and and can you build up to a conclusion
from
from that uh or you know from those
principles
and and then certainly if you come up
with some idea
and it appears to violate one of those
fundamental
truths then you're probably wrong or you
should get a really big prize or
something like that
um so this may seem like i don't know
maybe it may seem
sort of obvious when it's explained but
it's actually not what people do
reasoning my analogies is helpful
because it's a shortcut yeah um
and it's and it's mostly correct but but
uh it tends to be
most incorrect when you're dealing with
new things because
it's hard to analyze to something really
new the physics training is a very good
training
where it's a good framework for
reasoning where
you're trained to think about first
principles and reason from there
and that means boiling things down to
the most fundamental
truths and then connecting those truths
in a way
to try to understand how a reality is
because you know physics has this
problem where they're trying to figure
out things that are totally
counter-intuitive
and so they had to have a framework for
for getting there like quantum mechanics
is
incredibly counter-intuitive but it's
true
um and so you had so physics developed a
framework for for figuring out
uh things that aren't obvious and that's
why i think it's
it's it's a lot of advice but it's it's
the right framework
you must find a way to serve
martin luther king said that not
everybody can be famous but everybody
can be great because greatness is
determined
by service now we live in a world where
everybody wants to be famous
and where we admire people for just
being famous we think being known
brings us value the truth is all of that
will fade in time in three years you
won't be able to name the housewives
of atlanta
the real truth is that
service and significance
service and the significance that you
bring to your service
is that which is lasting so to be able
to
whatever your occupation or job or
talent or gift is our honorees today
getting doctor degrees to
apparently opposite fields hiv and aids
and the spoken word but what they have
in common
is service using the spoken word
in service to community and the world
using your knowledge and information
about hiv and aids and medicine
in service to the world and if you look
at all the most successful people
in the world whether they know it or not
they have that paradigm of service
everybody's talking about mark
zuckerberg and ipo
[Music]
service jay-z rapid
[Music]
service through the word to people
through song for many years i was really
just happy to be on tv and people would
stop and say oh you're on tv yeah i'm on
tv
i like being on tv it's a nice job
and it was about the time that i
received my
honorary doctorate from spelman around
1993 so i don't know if that had
something to do with it i thought of
myself as dr winfrey
that i went back and i took a long look
at what it was i was doing on
on tv and made a decision
that i was no longer going to just be on
tv
but i was going to use tv
as a platform as a force for good
and not be used by tv and i will tell
you
my decision to make that
significant change in the way i operated
on television using television as a
service
changed my career exponentially
service through medicine service through
art using whatever it is
you produce your product as a way of
giving back to the world when you shift
the paradigm of whatever it is
you choose to do to service and you
bring significance to that
success will i promise you
follow you service and significance
equals success when i first started
making money
and it was you know my salary or my
earnings
were published all over the place i mean
the first year i was like really did i
make that much money oh my god
um it was very difficult for me to
figure out
where my boundaries were because
i'd grown up poor and didn't have
anything so it's easy when you don't
have anything and people ask you for
money and they say i need 500
you say i don't have it because i'm just
trying to get my rent paid
it's harder when your multi-billion
dollar salary is now in the paper and
you get a lot of friends and cousins you
didn't have before
so how do you set boundaries for
yourself i was having trouble setting
boundaries myself
for myself for even strangers people
would just show up at my door in chicago
and say oh bro i left my husband please
help me and i would because she knows i
haven't
so don't try that now though okay
don't try that now i figured it out
so what i learned was is that oh
the reason why people keep showing up is
because my intention is to make them
think that i'm such a nice person
that you can ask me for anything
you can get me to do anything i'm gonna
say yes i'm gonna say
yes so when stevie called me this time
i thought i'd try out my first no on
stevie let's start big
he wanted me to donate some money to a
charity and i didn't want to donate to
the charity
because i have my own charities and i
care about a lot of people but the
the problem is when you you have money
everybody thinks you just want to give
to everything so every letter i ever get
starts with
we know you love the children
yes i do love the children but somebody
else is going to have to help the
children
so i said to stevie uh i said to stevie
no
and um as a person who has that disease
to please i was waiting for him then
just to say
i will never speak to you again
i will never call you i will never sing
a thong for you
and he didn't he just said okay
okay okay it's okay
he said okay check you later and
[Music]
what i learned from that is many times
you will have angst and worry about
things
and put yourself in a state like someone
said
this morning because their phone went
off they were mortified over a phone i
said really
you will put yourself in a state when
the other person really isn't even
thinking about you
so learning that i could
specifically determine for myself
what the boundaries were for me
what i wanted to do give my money
give my time give of my service to who i
wanted to give it to
when i did that i get to make that
decision and just because you get a
hundred requests a week
doesn't mean you have to try to fulfill
all of that
just because you have all of these
demands on
your time and on you doesn't mean that
you
have to say yes you get to decide
because you're the master of your fate
the captain of your soul as william
ernest hinley said
in invictus and understanding that
really
changed the meaning of my life in that i
was not
no longer driven by what other people
wanted me to do
but took charge of my own destiny making
choices based upon
what do i feel is the next right
move for me nobody's journey is seamless
or smooth
we all stumble we all have setbacks if
things go wrong
you hit a dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying time to
change
course so ask every failure this is what
i do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time i
say what is this here to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson you
get to move on
if you really get the lesson you pass
and you don't have to repeat the class
if you don't get the lesson
it shows up wearing another pair of
pants or skirt
to give you some remedial work and what
i found is
that difficulties come when you don't
pay attention to
life's whisper because life always
whispers to you first
first and if you ignore the whisper
sooner or later you'll get a scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question
not why is this happening but what is
this here to teach
me what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need
my friend cartoli who's written this
wonderful book
uh called a new earth that's all about
letting the awareness of who you are
stimulate
everything that you do he puts it like
this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge
with that situation instead and the
solution will arise from the challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means
acting with responsibility okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future
like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be
as beautiful as the students i wanted
every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint
i picked every pillow i was looking at
the grout in between the bricks
i knew every thread count of the sheets
i chose every girl from the villages
from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated
i was told that one of the dorm matrons
was suspected of sexual abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour
and then i said let's get to it that's
all you get
is a half an hour you need to focus on
the now
what you need to do now so i contacted a
child trauma specialist
i put together a team of investigators i
made sure the girls had counseling and
support
and gail and i got on a plane and flew
to south africa
and the whole time i kept asking that
question
what is this here to teach me and as
difficult as that experience has been
i got a lot of lessons i understand now
the mistakes i made
because i had been paying attention
to all of the wrong things i built that
school from the outside
in when what really mattered was the
inside out
so it's a lesson that applies to all of
our lives as a whole
what matters most is what's inside what
matters most is the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty
i got that lesson and what i know is is
that the girls
came away with something too they've
emerged from this more resilient
and knowing that their voices have power
24 of us were interviewed for a kfc
job 23 accepted i was the only guy
rejected
five six people went for looking for a
police job
five except i was the only one my cousin
and i
applied job as a as a as a server in a
four-star hotel by city
we weighed a long queue for two hours he
was accepted i really rejected
so my mother looked at me huh
you know what because but
i know this is a training course for me
before my 30 years old i'm a failure
people lose but i never give up i think
there is an opportunity there
and then i i was a teacher later
i graduated from university i was
teaching in the university for six years
number five because number five year i
was elected the best
teacher of my university elected by
students
so i said everything i taught
my students are the things i learned
from books
what if i go out spend the 10 years
experience
all the things whether fail or succeed i
go back to teach again
that was my original thing in doing
alibaba
so i never thought i could be rich i
never thought it would be successful
i never thought we could survive for 18
years
and then we made it the only thing that
today we should do is
share the experience and know how
especially share the mistakes
suffers with others my thinking is that
you guys remember if you want to be
successful
learn from the other people's mistakes
don't learn from the successful stories
successful stories they make
don't listen to that there are a lot of
reasons behind it
just like um i remember the first time
harvard business school came to us
say jack we want to write a case study
for you
yes years 2001 or 2000
they came they spent one week and they
write a report and i read no
i said this is not me and this is this
is you
that's no this is not us he said this is
you so the makeup is signed
and the case study go up and they
started teaching a lot of universities
the next five years they invited me to
go to the case study
and they always find a competitor of my
company
and if after every case study
alibaba will die that company will
succeed
all the students agree and actually
every five years all the competitors die
we still survive
so how can you study this kind of a
successful story
learn from the mistakes the other people
no matter how smart you are
you will encounter these mistakes
you learn from mistakes not because you
will be able to avoid mistakes
you were able to when these mistakes
come
this suffer comes you know how to deal
with it
how to face it i
i the book i want to write if i
if i want if i can
is alibaba 1001 mistakes
this is the most treasurable things
that in my life in my life is not how
much we achieved
it's how much we go through the tough
days
and mistakes and this is what
if you start to think now would be good
people ask me why
e-commerce so successful in china
our company alone is much bigger than
amazon
why e-commerce in china one of the
reasons why e-commerce in china is
success
successful because china had a terrible
infrastructure of commerce
right we don't have so many retail we
don't have
so many like walmart kmart everywhere
it's
it's just a terrible backward
retail system in china when internet
e-commerce come
people love it so so efficient why china
mobile phone you know grow much faster
than america
america and europe have such a great
such a great system of telephone
we don't have ten of them right amount
like 100 family can only have one
telephone that days
where mobile come we love that we just
go that
so there is a leapfrog we don't have
that rules or laws
most of the government offices they
don't know how to make rules laws for
internet because nobody realizes what
the internet
look like so that leave us a chance to
grow fast
europe very interesting you have such a
perfect
rules or loss then everything you do
let's follow the rules a lot
and everything we think about the thing
they do let's follow the rules a lot
and everything we think about they start
to worry when they worry they make a
rules loss
when we have a problems we start to
solve the problems
then think about rules or loss you have
a problem
like make rules a loss so
i worry about europe
i worry i worry about the worries of the
europe
if every africa does not worry asia does
not worry
why europe worry about right you don't
have
solutions for artificial intelligence oh
you know they're going to destroy a lot
of things in human life
forget it let me tell you artificial
intelligence
i think we only by using artificial
intelligence to arrest and
catch a lot of thieves my theory i told
my engineers i say
now when you love somebody you may not
have reasons
but when you hate somebody you have
logic and reasons we have logical
reasons
machine can always do better than that
so
we have a trillions of dollar
transaction on alipay every day
a lot of people want to steal the money
how can you oversee when you have like a
1 billion users using that there are so
many cheatings
human being cannot do it so we teach
machines to catch
all the thieves machine never forget no
matter how smart you are one person can
create
10 ways of cheating you are the smartest
person
in the world but we teach the machine
every way everything with this discover
from other people
the machine can remember over a hundred
thousand
ways of cheating when you start the
cheating machine find you
so one way bad guys
using artificial intelligence doing bad
things
other thing we're using artificial
intelligence
to catch bad guys so there is always
in any unbalance how you see the world
if you see technology revolution is a
problem
i'm sorry to say the problem just
started if you think
it's an opportunity the opportunity
just started the only thing is your
mentality
if the mentality is about a worry you'll
worry all the time
by the way all the entrepreneurs
if everything's ready everything's
perfect why they need you
because there is worries because there's
a problem
because of there's no this know that
that is your opportunity
that is our opportunity and keep on that
you believing you can do something
little by little
ten years later you'll be different
that's that's that's
who we are amazon one of the things we
try to do
is have multiple paths to yes
and so here's here's a little thought
experiment for you
if you are a junior
executive at amazon and that if
amazon did this in the typical kind of
corporate hierarchy way
you had an idea you need to get your
boss
to greenlight that idea and then your
boss's boss
needs to greenlight that idea and then
your boss's boss's boss
needs to greenlight that idea they're
probably five levels
or more before that idea gets the
go-ahead
assume instead that you're an
entrepreneur with a startup company idea
and you need venture capital you go to
sandhill road
and you go to the first venture
capitalist and they tell you no
and you go to the second one and they
tell you no
you're maybe your 20th one tells you yes
you've got 19 no's and one yes
and you're still good to go so that
that venture capital model is there's
multiple paths to yes there were 20
people who could give you a yes
and it didn't matter how many gave you a
no so if you want innovative thinking
you have to think about how can we get
you want high
a large number of high judgment people
empowered to green light things
you want multiple paths to yes you want
a system where
as a junior air force officer with a
good idea
the first five people tell me no and
somehow i can still go pursue that idea
so you gotta figure out that's an
organizational um
uh challenge that big organizations have
to figure out a way to do
and by the way i get you know
this happens all the time i'll say i
don't think that's a good idea but
somebody else will greenlight it and i'm
fine with that because usually
the cost of the experiments is pretty
small
things only get expensive when they work
right once something works you're like
whoa we need to double down on that now
and then the spending can get heavy and
then those become big consequential
decisions and that's where the hierarchy
and the
using the judgment of the most senior
people to me this really helps now that
you have about 600 000 employees i
calculated you're adding about 250
people a day
um you've mentioned that you're trying
to fend off day two yeah
and you've said that day two is stasis
followed by irrelevance
followed by excruciatingly painful
decline followed by death
that is why it is always day one yeah
yeah how's that work
well so day one and this is a phrase
that we use at amazon all the time i've
been using it's in my first
annual shareholder letter from 20 years
ago
and we say it's always day one and it
needs to be day one for the reason that
you just
mentioned um and how do you so the real
question for me is how do you go about
maintaining a day one culture you know
it's great to have
the um the scale of amazon we have
financial resources we have lots of
brilliant people
we can accomplish great things we have
global scopes we have operations all
over
the world but the downside of that
is that you can lose your nimbleness you
can lose your entrepreneurial spirit you
can lose your
that kind of heart the the that that
small companies often have
and so if you could have the best of
both worlds
if you can have that entrepreneurial
spirit and heart
while at the same time having all the
advantages that come with scale and
scope
i think think of the things that you
could do and and so
how the question is how do you achieve
that um this
the scale is good because it makes you
robust you know a
a big boxer can take a punch to the head
the question is you also want to dodge
those punches you'd like to be nimble
you want to be big and nimble and i find
there are a lot of things that are
protective of the day one mentality i
already spent some time on one of them
which is
customer obsession i think that's the
most important thing if you can
and it gets harder as you get bigger
when you're a little tiny company so
you're a 10-person startup company
every single person in the company is
focused on the customer
when you get to be a bigger company
you've got all the mil you've got middle
managers and you've got all these
layers and the those people aren't on
the front lines
they're not interacting with customers
every day they're insulated from
customers
and they start to manage not the
customer
happiness directly but they start to
manage through proxies like
metrics and processes and some of those
things can become bureaucratic so
it's very challenging but one of the
things that happens
is the decision-making velocity slows
down
and i think the reason one of the
reasons that that happens
is that people all the junior executives
inside the big company
start to model all decisions as if they
are heavyweight irreversible
highly consequential decisions and so
even
two-way doors you could make you make a
decision it's the wrong decision you can
just back up back through the door and
try again
even those reversible decisions start to
be made with heavyweight processes
and so you can teach people that these
pitfalls and and traps and then teach
them to avoid
those traps and that's what we're trying
to do at amazon so that we can maintain
our inventiveness and our heart and our
kind of small company's spirit even as
we have the scale and scope of a larger
company
i advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job
i mean you know don't sleepwalk through
life and don't don't say it's all going
to be great
you know i'll do this and i'll do that
and you know i'm just marking time to
get to be older that
i've told people that's like saving up
sex for your old age i mean it just is
not
it is not a good idea
what are you urging them to do i'll
explain it
guess what i'm talking about that
now it it you just
yeah you really want to be doing what
you love doing
and you can't necessarily find it on
your first job right but
don't give up before you find it mr
buffett in the past you invested in
china
south korea and israel um and recently
you partnered with 3g
capital and joshua lemon from brazil
over for the heinz deal uh does this
mean are you tempted to venture
into the brazil market next i didn't get
the question
question you did the heinz deal the
question is are you gonna invest in
brazil
next oh uh i don't know where i'm gonna
invest next that's what
that's what makes my job interesting i
mean i'm i'm
i'm not kidding i mean if you went out
and played golf
and every drive went in the hole you'd
give up the game wouldn't be interesting
i mean
what's interesting is when you get in
the rough and you have to come out and a
few things like that so
i i love the fact that i don't know what
i'm going to do next you mentioned the
israel investment
in 2006 in the fall
i got a letter from a fellow and i never
heard of him
and i never heard of the company he was
talking about but he said my name is
eton wardheimer
and i want to tell you a little about my
company ishkar the letter was a page and
a half long
and he said if he sold the company the
family sold the company the only company
they wanted to sell it to was berkshire
hathaway
and if i was interested they'd be glad
to come over from israel and explain it
to me and it was a
it just jumped off the page that this
was an interesting idea so i
emailed them and they came over very
shortly and and we bought the business
we we handed them
four billion dollars for 80 percent of a
company where i'd never seen it or
anything
etan kept saying you got to come over to
israel and see the plants and everything
you won't believe how wonderful they are
and i said hey tom
i don't go to council bluffs iowa you
know i mean
i am doing fine in omaha and uh
he said no you know you got to see it i
said no no i don't i
said we can make a deal without seeing
it he said well if you buy if you buy
the company will you come and see it
i said if we buy the company i'll come
so we bought the company
and i went over there and it's true i've
never seen plants like this it was the
greatest operation i've ever seen
and etan said to me he said you know
that's why i want you to come over to
see these things i said listen
if i'd come and see them i'd pay more
money so
so it uh we
we have a wonderful partnership with the
people in israel but i don't know
tomorrow
uh our partnership with the people in
brazil with george apollo lemon and his
associates
they are sensational people i i got to
know george apollo when i was on the
port of gillette with him
and the opportunity to buy into a
wonderful business
like heinz and to be partners and they
do
they'll do all the heavy lifting they
run the place uh with georgie pollon
associates i mean it's just it's a it's
a great opportunity for us
and i don't know what the opportunity
will be tomorrow with george apollo is
last december
uh i was going out to boulder colorado
where he had a group that met
and he said i think i've got an idea
might interest you when i get out there
so i went out there and
uh and as we came back on the plane he
explained what he was thinking about in
terms of heinz and i said
count me in and uh and i will tell you
one other thing which is
quite impressive about him after i said
that and
went a little a little further on the
thing he sent me a
one-page governance description of how
it
would work between the two of us and he
sent me a very brief description of
what he thought would be a fair deal for
both of us i didn't have to change a
word
i mean those are the kind of people you
like to associate with all of you in
this
room have the brains to do extremely
well in life
you've all got the energy to do
extremely well on life and then the
question is how do you apply it
if you've got a 200 horsepower motor you
get 200 horsepower out of it
you get your full potential or do you
get 100 horsepower or 50 horsepower
now there's two things that can hold you
back
in getting the full horsepower out of
your your engine whatever it may be all
of you have big enough
engines and one of those is a lack of
education but that probably isn't going
to happen to very many people in this
room
if you did have a lack of education if
you didn't have a chance to get a decent
education in life
it wouldn't make any difference what
that potential was because you'd never
unlock it but the second most important
thing
and equally as important is in terms of
the habits that you develop in terms of
what you do with yourself
when we hire people we look for three
qualities
we look for integrity we look for
intelligence
and we look for energy but if they don't
have the first one integrity
the other two will kill you because if
you're hiring somebody without integrity
you really want to be dumb and lazy
don't you i mean you know
last thing in the world you want forms
to be smart and energetic so
smart and energetic only goes with
integrity
but the nice thing about
you know you make your own decision on
that you can't change
your iq or how far you can throw a
football or how high you can jump
or the color of your hair very easily
but you can
elect to have integrity that matches
anybody else's and if you match that
with intelligence which you have and
energy which you have
uh you will get an extraordinary result
and you'd be very foolish to sell me 10
of yourself for 50 000. on the other
hand if you don't match it with that
your potential will
in a significant part go unused well in
1973
uh the washington post company gone
public in 1971 right about the pentagon
papers type
time but in 73 uh the nixon
administration
uh was through bibi rebozo who was a
palo nixon's
they were challenging uh the licenses of
two of the florida television stations
the post owned so the stock went from
37 down to 16. now at 16 there were
about 5 million shares outstanding so
the whole washington post company was
selling for 80 million dollars
and that included the newspaper four big
tv stations newsweek you know and some
other assets and no debt to speak of
so the washington post company which was
intrinsically worth four or five hundred
million dollars
was selling for about 80 million in the
market we bought most of our stock at
about the equivalent of 100 million in
the market
and and it was it was ridiculous i mean
you had a business that unquestionably
was worth four or five times what it was
selling for and
nixon wasn't going to put them out of
business when you're doing these
analyses then
and now do you have computers that help
you or how did you actually
read all what do you guys get written
materials or how did you in those days
get the materials to read about the
washington post and how do you do it
today well
same pretty much the same way except
there's fewer opportunities now but
uh i met bob woodward back and and and
he just
come out with all the president savannah
and all of a sudden as a
below 30 years of age he was getting
quite wealthy and we had we had
breakfast or lunch over at the madison
hotel he said what do i do with this
money and i said i said investing is
just about assigning yourself the right
story i said imagine ben bradley this
morning said to you
what is the washington post company
worth what would you do if you have to
write the story in a month you'd go out
and interview tv
brokers and newspaper brokers and the
owners and you'd try and value each
asset
i said that's what i do i assign myself
the right story and
it's it's nothing more than that now
there's some stories i can't write if
you ask me to
write a story on you know what is some
glamorous
but non-profit making business worth i
don't know how to write that story but
if you ask me to write a story on what
is
potomac electric power worth or
something like that i can write the
story and that's what i'm doing every
day i'm assigning myself a story and
then i go out and so you get
why should someone like myself or a
business owner
get a lot of credit get cash out even if
they're already thriving and doing well
they've got cash in the bank what's the
importance of that
well everybody does different things and
you got to do with what you're
comfortable with
and and and i've always been comfortable
with borrowing money
but but but i talk but that's also my
success
because the way you look at every
unless you're a tech baby again the
world
was created because of leverage finance
okay there's the reason that you had
you know all the tech companies and the
media companies and
and the great big casinos in vegas the
things that cost
billions of dollars a lot of money you
did it with leverage finance with
my good friend in california michael
milken really
came up with but that's why there was
such an explosiveness in the 80s because
of leverage finance
i've always been scared of debt but i
haven't been scared of debt i never had
a problem with using it but i talked in
my book is
this is the problem that we all do is
say you you have a small business and
you want to go out
and and borrow some money and you do a
performa for the bank a budget
you know to keep it simple for people
people always give a budget that is the
best case scenario and they
start to drink their own kool-aid and
think that's what they're going to do
well one of the things that objections
yeah or even next year and what i've
always done is i've done that for the
bank
but even today in a deal that i bought
last week i want a worst-case scenario
the world's coming apart okay and all of
a sudden all your expensive counts are
gone and are people still gonna eat
steaks yeah and i
run a budget in a performa based on that
wow so
best case scenario worst case scenario
because you know what happens 80 percent
of the time the worst case scenario
really yes that's just life right and
and
and and that's a tool that i've always
used
because you what happens is they give
that to the bank or to whoever
and all of a sudden you start drinking
your own kool-aid like that's easy to do
it's not easy to do being successful in
business is not easy
yeah but that's why i talk about just
simple tools in here
when harper collins came to me they
didn't say we want a life story
we see you on your show we see you on
these business talk shows
we read these articles we want you to
write about your
tools why you've never failed and you've
made it through all these recessions
rather you're a corporate person or or
you're an entrepreneur
why did you get to go like this it never
really went like this
when you have a good idea right you ask
your friends you ask for feedback around
you say oh i'm all excited it's a great
idea
right my friends like it i can't find it
what do you do next you go to google
right and you put it in there and you
say it's this this this this you find 50
different keyword searches
and you say there's nothing there right
wow there must be it must be a great
idea no one else is doing it
wrong the reason there's nothing there
is the 15 people who did it before you
are out of business their web servers
are down and they're not indexed anymore
and there's no sense of history and a
lot of the things that are happening
you know because and particularly with
mobile apps because
there's no real web there there's like a
one-page website up that directs you to
the mobile app
there's nothing indexing the app and so
a lot of 50 different people are doing
the same app and
you know and because you can't get a url
it's
you know the xx app right and it's xxx
app and it's hard to find
the comparables and it's hard to learn
from the history of it and so
it's whether it's google whether it's
facebook
the real challenge right now in starting
a company is you can't learn from
history because all the history is gone
and that's all at least to have that
maybe it holds us back and maybe you
know
it's the worst thing that can happen is
you know being you know ignorant of what
happened
might you know is probably better in a
lot of cases and but sometimes it's not
and so
um i think that's one of the biggest
challenges that entrepreneurs face today
that there's no history to to really go
back to look at i
went to dallas after college because a
bunch of my buddies were down there
and i got a job working as a bartender
at night and was looking for a job
during the day and got a job working for
a retail software company
and this was in the early days of pcs
and was doing okay
there and then about nine months in i
made
um let me add i was living six guys in a
three-bedroom apartment
and i was sleeping on the floor it was
the rattiest
nastiest hole you've ever seen in your
life i mean
and i literally didn't have a closet
didn't have a drawer
all my was in a pile on the floor i had
my one towel that i stole from motel 6
that had a hole in it
that was mine um and so i was
trying to grind it out and learn tech
which i really
realized that i loved and i made the one
day i called up my boss a guy named
michael humecki h-u-m-e-c-k-i
and i said michael i've got this deal
i'm going to close now it's 1500
commissioned to me which meant i can
move out of the show and and so
i said one of my responsibilities was to
open up the retail store
you know make sure the door was open the
floors were clean and all that kind of
stuff i said look
i've got this big deal i want to close
it and he said no you need to be at the
store i'm like
i got someone to watch goes no you need
to be at the store so i made the
executive decision that if i went and
picked up a fifteen thousand dollar
check for this
company um your business software he
would see the light
and all would be good and i'd have my
1500 commission
fired my ass um seriously michael
humecki
and i'm not going to assuming you've
spoken to him since then
one time one time literally after
broadcast.com went public he sent me
a letter asking if i would invest in his
company
you should bring him on shark tank
anyway so that was the only time i
talked to michael humecki
and so there's a shark king tank company
from last season called mush
right cool stuff it's like this um
oatmeal that they packaged it's fresh
dried oatmeal
that they packaged with a little spoon
and you it has to be refrigerated but
you just grab it and go
and the the response was great from the
show
and now like i just saw their numbers
they went from 50 000 in sales to 100
000
to 125 000 in three straight months it's
not scale but they're
growing right and they're all of a
sudden like okay we got to go raise
money and we got to do yada yada
scale is hard not just because of the
economic cost
but also because of the people cost and
the mind share cost
it's hard when you're dealing with a
major company and in particular if
you're dealing with a big company like a
walmart
or costco or whatever because you only
get one shot of those guys
and so like i told mush with whole foods
they're interested i'm like you're not
ready you're not ready
you have got to you got to crawl before
you ball
you know and
and and and so i told him
it's going to be painful not to go after
that big customer
but think about what happens if you go
after it
and a it's going to take capital you
don't have and you're going to borrow it
or b it doesn't work out and they return
it all then all of a sudden you're out
of business
and so you're you're right that you need
capital to scale
but you also need the confidence
that you can scale and that you can keep
your customers happy
and so i always tell people get to the
point
where you have you you've taken care of
the customers that you can take care of
once you can demonstrate that then you
can get smart money
and you're talking from a position of
power and then you can go to the
walmarts of the world the costco's
and you may not even have to raise money
they may even provide
po leverage or po support or connect you
with a bank that does
and so i guess i guess what i'm saying
is
don't get too far ahead of yourself
because sometimes
sales can be a lot more expensive than
you think they are
and you've got to be careful i've seen
several my shark tank companies try to
get too big too fast
and it almost put them out of business
nice is way undervalued
you know particularly in this day and
age you know if you turn on the news
everything seems like it's going to get
blown up
right being nice just makes life so much
easier and look i learned the hard way i
had to have my partner todd
came to me one day and he goes i like to
curse
he goes i don't care about cursing but
you curse too much
not everybody's as accepting as cursing
as you are
calm the [ __ ] down
and i took that to heart not so much the
cursing part but
but i just i it became apparent to me
that
the nicer i got the more effective
people around me got
the more productive they got the more
sales we had
i was undervaluing nice you know i
started my
my first company after i got fired from
a job and i was 24 just turned 24
my first real company if you will and i
was always go go go go all consumed
right live it eat it sleep and breathe
and i knew people couldn't keep up or
work as hard as many hours as me
but i wanted them to and we were
successful
and we didn't have much turnover but i
could have done a better job if i were
nicer
and broadcast.com i got a little bit
nicer right
as things but then once i got to the
mavs and and
some of these other companies and todd
reminded me you know and
really told me you know just nice
nice works and so when you find yourself
going to work when you're finding
yourself dealing with customers
when you're finding yourself making
decisions we all get that object right
that feeling in her stomach that
tenseness that stress at various points
and times that we all have to go through
but sometimes you just need to calm the
down right
take a deep breath and be nice because
you'll find out that people will do much
more if you reduce the stress of people
and you're nice you're going to have
such a huge advantage
no matter what your technology is no
matter how it compares even if it's a
download for an app
people will still have to deal with you
your culture will come through
being nice being being supportive
reducing stress that all comes through
even in and out
what advice would you have for managers
or companies that are really working
through change and struggling
let let me uh define creative
destruction or
i will use schumpeter's
definition here's the way he put it it
is not price and output competition
which counts but the competition from
the new product
the new technology the new source of
supply
the new type of organization which
commands a decisive
cost or quality advantage and which
strikes
not at the margins of the profits and
the outputs
but at their foundations and their very
lives
so that's what we're talking about here
this is
not life or death for us individually
but life and death
for our businesses and our jobs and so
what we do
to communicate this is get
all our employees to understand that
change is a risk for all of us
but not changing isn't a risk
it's suicide it is a certainty
that you are going out of business and
you are going to if you
individual employee if you're not
changing and improving
and working on that every day you're not
going to have your job
whereas if you take what you think are
risks and you find
a way to eliminate most of your job
because there's a way to do this more
efficiently or to bypass do it a
completely different way
here at coke you're not going to lose
your job you're going to be a hero we
started
um you know there's like a cpa
yeah chartered you know uh accountant
and there's the cfa chartered financial
analyst
there was nothing for financial risk
managers you couldn't get certified
so i was talking to my my boss and
became a
friend and was like you know why don't
we just kind of create an
exam for risk managers because it
doesn't exist
and he was kind of like yeah well you
created an industry yeah craig how do
you how do you create an exam and so we
started talking to people
and um basically they're like well you
can't just create a certification
like who are you you're like 24 years
old you can't just start an exam like
who's gonna like accredit it or who's
gonna and i said no no we're just gonna
start an association wow and a
not-for-profit association and that
association will
credit it you know and then we'll we'll
kind of do the exam
and so i was like you know that's crazy
you can't do it so i said you know
forget it
i'm jumping in what we're going to do is
we're going to set up a website we're
going to put up
a date for the exam the first thing we
did was date we just picked a date like
it's
may you know whatever i don't remember
the year 1998.
here's the day it's new york city actual
date and here's the outline of all the
things that are going to be on the exam
send a check for 500 bucks and you got
your seat and then that's it and so we
just put it up there
and all of a sudden we started getting
checks people started sending checks
and it was like so we looked at each
other like i think we need to write this
exam now oh my gosh there was no exam at
the time no it was just we just started
with the date and the and the agenda for
you know the
the topics yes we started getting all
these checks and we got 34 checks
17 000 and 34 people and so we decided
so
me and lev sat down and we spent
weekend after weekend nights and things
writing this entire exam
on every topic and we gave also
recommended readings as well
and then we we went to new york city we
rented our place and we administered
this exam to 34 people
and then we went home and corrected it
we decided where the pass fail was
we sent certificates to the people that
passed and now today it's still
in like 50 countries around the world
there's like thousands of people taking
this example you're a trip man
like like no but but it's just a great
and i'm just
i'm just saying that only because people
think that when you start something yes
it has to be like buttoned up or you
need to have a plan you need to know
your next step or whatever
and what i always say is you know just
take the biggest
step you can with your next move
i worked at mcdonald's i got fired i
worked at a furniture store i got fired
i worked in a car dealership i was fired
six times from the same guy
i just quit leaving and i've been fired
so many times i finally figured out how
to get fired and keep my job
i mean really so talent uh i'm
i'm a sales guy because not because i
wanted to that was not something i
wanted to do
my dad my dad was a sales guy my dad
told my mom before he died
tell those boys to learn how to sell he
knew he was going to die and he's like
tell those boys to learn how to sell and
they can go anywhere
uh i i didn't know that my mom didn't
tell me that until i was like
uh 25 26 years old and i had to take a
sales job
she she wanted me to be a more a
professional
uh so i went and got an accounting
degree got out of college there was 25
unemployment i didn't know it i you know
i didn't i didn't know anything about
sales i didn't i didn't go to college
and become a salesman
but it was the only job i could get when
i was 25 years old it was be unemployed
or take this job selling toyotas i
didn't even know what a toyota
was to th this is this is years ago
toyota wasn't even
uh a thing yet and um
so i took this job that i did i thought
it was just gonna be a temporary job i
said okay i'm gonna do this for
until i can get a real job and
that ended up becoming my career i
actually hated sales
because all the jobs i had outside of
mcdonald's were
part-time sales jobs i sold clothes you
know i remember
selling clothes i'd sell i'd sell an
outfit i'd make six bucks on it
so kind of hard to get excited about six
dollars but it was six dollars more than
i had and i was trying to put myself
through college and
and pay for all kind of ridiculous
things i was doing at the time
and um i
i i leaned into the sales thing and
started learning it i was just shooting
some material today for cardone
university we
we have probably without me over
over promoting my own product we
probably have
the most viewed sales training system in
the world today
and i'm saying that not to brag but to
tell the viewer
this came out of a job i didn't want and
didn't like
but when i leaned into it and said hey i
need to commit to this thing because i'm
just gonna
i have to learn how to do this i have to
learn how to bring revenue in
and whether i liked it or not i needed
to learn i needed to learn the money
game the money game starts with
in accounting and it might have been the
thing i learned in accounting as i sit
here and tell you the story because
in accounting the top
i remember studying financial statements
in accounting classes uh
it was uh counting um the principles of
accounting i thought i was gonna learn
how to make money
that's not what they're teaching there
but i remember there was on a page
in the accounting book the blue
accounting book that i tested and hated
there was a page about an income
statement and then they would compare
income statements to these companies
well the top thing of
every page was income revenue
or gross sales and later looking back
didn't know it then but looking back
later i'm like oh that's the most
important part of a company
if it wasn't the most important part of
a company they wouldn't put it at the
top
of the income statement yeah on every
income statement everywhere in the world
it doesn't matter whether you're in
china or chicago
the top three lines they might be
different words there it is all
describing
gross sales revenue revenue by
department
uh gross demand domestic product how
much
revenue is coming through a country that
is what determines whether or not a
household
a department or a company is viable
and i have been fighting the top three
lines of my personal
financial statement which everybody has
won
and it's called sales so once i leaned
into it boom i started making money man
it was
it was literally that simple i'm going
to learn how to bring revenue into my
household
i was 25 years old had no money lived in
a
lived in an apartment and my rent was
275 a month
i was late on it four times a year every
three months i was late because i'd go
up and down
and when i leaned into it i was saying
hey i made an extra thousand
dollars when i was 25 years old i'm like
wow that was the most important money
i've ever made in my whole life
because it gave me an idea that i could
control my income
what were the lessons you learned uh you
know starting from essentially zero
having no money no context
no uh relationships no uh opportunities
in a town that you went to for this show
what did you realize
were the keys to actually making money
even if you didn't have any
well as you see the show you see that i
actually never make any money
right so uh the two girls they they
actually
they follow three of us and the two
girls went out and got a job in the
first week
and and i'm not saying that's right or
wrong or my ways more better or worse
but but they are strategies okay they're
different strategies
i was not there to get a job or to earn
money
i was there looking for one thing
opportunity i never spent time looking
for money ever the entire
uh 90 days okay i'm not looking for
money i was actually looking for
contracts
through the contacts i wasn't looking
for money because i knew the evaluation
of the company
in the last um segment
an evaluator will come in and determine
what my company's worth my new company
right that i created
and at that point i just need to
validate to him dude my company's
worth this based on that the entire 90
days
i never touched the first hundred they
gave me and this was to prove to people
do you do not need money
like it's just it's not true you need
money you do need
contacts you need people you need people
you need people
you need the right people though the
right people that are already in play
okay just because a guy's got money i
remember
a a billionaire friend of mine uh you
know he could buy a jet
and i said hey bob should i buy a jet he
said you should i shouldn't
meaning grant should because and he's
way wealthier than i am he could have
bought 40 of them
he's like i don't have a place to go in
mine you have a you can use yours every
day
so you got to find somebody that's in
place somebody that not just has money
but somebody that wants
to do more with their money so you'll
notice in the first uh
10 days i don't spend a hun any money i
don't spend money on shelter not on food
and not on water
nothing then what i do is i end up
accumulating assets
and it's unfortunate that the viewer
doesn't see this within five days i have
two vehicles
one was given to me by discovery and the
other one was a forty thousand dollar
jeep
that i basically used uh from ryan
this guy i met and told him i'm gonna
sell your jeep
i'm gonna drive it around town and put
10 miles a day on it and i'm gonna sell
it well
that's a forty three thousand dollar
asset uh my truck was worth four grand
i still had my hundred dollars i lived
in a forty six thousand dollar rv
that i was trying to sell so yeah uh and
then what what's the other thing i did
and i picked up ten thousand dollars
to do in a 15 partnership in the equity
of the upside of this guy's company so
literally in 10 days
i was accumulating contacts that could
get me equity and the
important part of that story is man go
get you some equity
you know jay-z talks about this you're
getting you know so many of you young
brothers are getting in advance while
i'm picking up the equity
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
what do you say when you see yourself in
the mirror when it's just you when
you're all alone it's just you
you see yourself in the mirror what do
you say do you say great things
or do you beat yourself up most people
they might act confident and seem like
they have it all put together
but secretly they're fighting their own
battles and at home
in private the comfort of their own home
they're their own worst enemies
the secret is to be your own biggest
critic as well as your biggest fan
the push you give yourself has to be
from a place of love and potential
not lack and despair so i recently
posted on instagram
a little cartoon of me passing by a
mirror and you see my reflection in the
mirror
and the caption says i love you and then
i challenge people to say hey what do
you what do you say to yourself when you
look in the mirror
and giving them an 18-day challenge to
say every time you see a reflection of
yourself
to say something positive whether it's i
love you or give yourself a compliment
something positive because i think most
people live in the land of negativity
all we see is all the negative things
that we're doing and all the things that
didn't work out and things that could
have been better
and that can actually be very healthy i
think you need to be your own biggest
critic i think you need to have
higher standards for yourself than what
you're currently doing but it only works
being your own biggest critic only works
when it's based off a foundation of love
when it's based on a foundation of i am
an amazing human being and i love myself
and i suck at all of these skills the
problem that most people have is you see
that you suck at a scale that you didn't
get the result that you're not good on
camera the first time you go
out you didn't get the result you didn't
land the sale you didn't make the deal
you didn't get the date you know
whatever it is you didn't get the result
and then you think that you suck as a
human because you don't have the skills
it's the opposite you're you're amazing
as a human
it has to be from a foundation of love
that you love yourself
and that you suck at the skills and then
you can beat yourself up over how do i
get better how do i improve how do i
acquire the skills how do i move forward
towards my goals
most people are their own biggest critic
but they're not the biggest fan
and i'm going to give you a three-step
process on how to change it step number
one
is take the 18-day flexi-x challenge so
if you want to go to every chemical.com
flex the x
dot pdf you can get the same calendar
that i use it's not here
it's somewhere it's in my bedroom so
where i usually keep it and
every day for the next 18 days you
challenge yourself that whenever i see
myself
reflective surface a mirror the cell
phone
whatever i'm going to say something
positive to myself in fact
just make that your cell phone
background and that when you see your
your login screen or your home screen
on your cell phone background on your
desktop it says something positive about
you
and it's a reminder i have to say
something positive about myself just for
18 days
try it flex the ex challenge why 18 days
because it takes at least 18 days to
build a habit
science says that it takes 18 to 254
days to build a habit it's why i have my
254 series because i'm there with you
every step of the way
and the average is actually 66 days of
consecutive action means no time off no
days off to build a habit
but the minimum is 18 days so just try
it for 18 days
just try it what's going to happen in 18
days the worst is you're saying
something you don't believe about
yourself for 18 you can handle
it you'll be okay the best case scenario
is you actually start to love yourself a
little bit more
and the things that you can do when you
believe in yourself and you love
yourself
are tremendous so step number one is
take the 18 day flex dx
i love you challenge step number two is
being your own biggest critic as well as
your biggest fan you need to do both and
so
ask yourself the criticism that i'm
giving myself when i look at my videos
when i look at my
content when i look at how i'm handling
my team when when you look at all the
things that you're supposed to be doing
that you are doing on a daily basis and
you beat yourself up
identify the parts that are just a skill
set
that you rock that you're amazing that
you're the best
but you just don't have the skill set
yet and how do you fix it how do you
acquire
the skill set do more practice through
more research
through model and success that you can
get there so split it up
having that cognitive ability to say i'm
being hard on myself
but really it's just a skill set that
i'm lacking and i'm awesome
makes a big difference so start doing it
today
and step number three is kick yourself
forward not down
this often comes when you're comparing
yourself to others you're comparing
yourself to
somebody else who's in your field who's
ahead of you or somebody who you went to
high school with or university with and
and they have a bigger job than you are
making more money and have more kids or
whatever it is that you're jealous of
you kick yourself down you say i suck
well
they they're off doing this and they
acquired this by the time that they were
your age and you suck you're not doing
anything you're nowhere close
right that's kicking yourself down
that's not helpful
what you need to do is kick yourself
forward what you need to do is look at
that and say that's what's possible
that's the potential that's what that's
what you can be capable of doing
but here's the thing i think you
actually need the kick i think the
comparison is good i think it's healthy
i think the problem with the comparison
is you're only looking at it from the
negative
because you actually don't love yourself
yet you have to build that up
right do the 18 day flex challenge it's
based out of love to say that this is
what's possible
because without the kick without the
comparison you stay where you are
the key though is you're kicking
yourself forward to say that's what's
possible
that's what i want to create somebody
else has done it i can do it too i've
got michael jordan level talent i'm
going to go off and crutch it
instead of kicking yourself down and
saying that you suck and you're never
going to get there
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there